so it's a free country these were made
cat made these rinks is a Crocs
so I'm gonna fight and this is what a
man decides who he is and what it's
worth the predecessor of an anthem so
guess what
Oh
[Applause]
all right I know you want Crocs that bad
good 8126 Wilshire Boulevard
he Machado did you pull your nuts and
Bulldog them all the spare and love more
brother how you got a nice nice tight
high ass till I got a nice hand I didn't
expect you know me I get brown light
[ __ ] here's one the best ass I've seen
in the game it's plumping it's high and
it's tight and your bullets look like
what I thought your balls would look
like yeah they're old but I'm very good
that legit took everything in my power
cuz I didn't know that was gonna happen
for me to not take a lick yeah that's
what happened home in your mouth
cuz when he makes him when he puts him
out like that cuz I thought that my dad
was worried but it's not cured the baby
brain tell you a story when I was young
man I was probably 18 years old in
Russia in communist Russia i hook up
with this gal I meet these two girls in
the lobby turned out there were probably
hookers now our girls I need help with
their rent now listen my buddy he
couldn't do it with Christina it was
Christina and Svetlana and he couldn't
he couldn't pull the trigger or and get
his yeah he was you know he'd never been
around another guy me I don't give a
[ __ ]
I'll have second need any with my boys
we've been honest that's it
hey honey what yeah but you know I mean
it's ah no hey nuts were out no I know
but just take it easy apologize and and
the point is I'm there and he can't
perform so I go whoa come join he's a
fat display that's right so I'm giving
it to Svetlana giving it to her at 17 18
years old condom or no condom of course
no condom now yeah come on is Russia
that's Russia it's Russian I have a
recipe this is 1989 oh yeah they know 85
maybe I can already see before you were
good so my mother called me that's a
whole nother story doesn't matter now
now she comes over it now as I'm going
to town on on fat Lana and then I go to
town because did not come back to
Svetlana curvy curvy ladies oh the best
the best the best the best the best
Christina a bit my boy holy cheese no
just the cheek it was so shocking to me
Oh like that Wow and did you would you
would you drop your American load you
know believe it or not I don't remember
any time any time I go I'm sorry oh my
god sorry they're so distracting dude no
please don't get your do like I'll
[ __ ] [ __ ] plants can feel like I've
been 90% plant pace I'm gonna be honest
with you right now if because last time
I was about being a relationship but I'm
just [ __ ] horny because I haven't had
meat so if you pull your dick out
they're gonna bug to get sucked all
right well here you go
well you got the pretty ambidextrous mpi
dextrous nose yeah I do
dexterity if your feet are just even a
corgi and you're this is cat these are
amazed I'm why they drive vaginas up
everywhere but I'm gonna wear these cat
I said if I set them on fire I love no
by all means I actually hate Crocs ooh
but they're cute shame I'm gonna these
have got to be like a hung up good real
nice awesome what do they say on them
but it says rinks
this is wrinkly old rink I thought his
ass was I thought his skin was no I'll
give him that he has a JLo ass
I gotta get a fat you said I'm built
like a frog yep because when I did my
genome I was so excited it's mostly fast
twitch muscle yeah go for speed and
power and I was like Brandon because
you're built like a frog Kermit the Frog
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]